Carol do you know why you're here
what don't play dumb with me I know what
you did I didn't do anything we're
taking unprescribed antibiotics
Oh Percy were sick you just sneezed
wha-what okay what's so bad about taking
it into my eyes you are allowing the
enemy to become a stronger enemy our
germs don't use informal terms here
these are enemies okay all bacteria the
ribosome is made up of two subunits a
large one and a small one the large
subunit contains the active site so it
creates the new peptide bonds the
proteins are synthesized the small
subunit makes sure that the information
flows correctly during protein synthesis
antibiotics inhibit the ribosome for
making proteins either by interfering
and messenger RNA translation or by
blocking the formation of peptide
coffins bacteria needs proteins if there
ain't no proteins right go back here
here take these
I mean a glycoside antibiotics I need to
put a tight pocket on a small rendazzo
causing it to improperly pair codons an
anticodon which results as I said if
this is a rabbit protein killing the
bacteria so I'm good that no the
bacteria are fighting back bacteria has
fun many ways to resist one of those
methods would be the use of Munich
glycoside modifying enzymes amino
glycosides ease amine and hydroxyl
groups for binding to RNA amino
glycosides modifying enzymes add new
chemical groups to these aliens and
hydroxyls so that's a drug can no longer
bind the bacteria will be able to
continue to thrive and multiply and
thanks to you taking unnecessary and
unprescribed antibiotics bacteria is
probably already succeeded in mutating
and becoming a stronger and now you can
often find more expensive medicines
well how do we prevent take advice from
your health worker when you're taking
antibiotics
finish your prescription large writing
this down write this down never share or
use leftover antibiotics and you better
wash your hands